brothers and sisters and dear friends
Jordan Peterson just released the video
a couple of hours ago and I was really
looking forward to this video Until I
watched it and I was a bit taken aback
it was a bit condescending I don't know
if you did intentionally unintentionally
we assume the best but let's watch this
video and you guys tell me if you feel
the same way I did
please forgive my presumption if you
would
it is time for those of you in the
Muslim world
to stop fighting among yourselves you
Shiites and sunnis
and also time to stop regarding the
Christians and even more specifically
the Jews as your enemies
Muslims
reach across the sectarian divide
Shiites find a Sunni pen pal communicate
with someone on the other side sunnis do
the same
and then maybe Reach Out tentatively
to a Christian or even heaven forbid a
Jew let's see if we can unite as people
of the book and negotiate our way toward
the paradise that we might truly
and jointly Attain
guys before the video starts I've come
together with Hummer charity to help
those in Afghanistan who have suffered
the earthquake on our homeless before
the video starts please donate to that
in the description box below enjoy the
video may Allah bless you guys
while I was watching this video I was
actually very excited because I look
forward to watching Jordan Peterson's
video after his discussion with Muhammad
hijab and other Muslims you know it just
showed that you know he's slim sincere
he seems to open the dialogue and he
opens to it seems he's open to learning
but I was a bit taken back when I
watched the video because I found it a
bit condescending I found it a bit of
offensive now yes okay like okay you
know maybe Jordan Peterson's watching to
be like oh here we go you know we're
living in a culture where everyone gets
offended I'm not talking about it in
that way I found it a little a little
bit disappointed and I don't believe
it's coming from a malicious place but
maybe from a place of um and I mean it
with all due respect I do not mean it in
a rude way but maybe from a place of not
knowing you know I'm not going to use
the word ignorance because it has those
negative connotations with it but from a
place that he doesn't know because when
I was watching the video it just felt as
if like I understand he was passionate
he had the message of you know there's a
greater devil that we all need to fight
Etc
um and I know exactly what he's talking
about but when he was keep repeatedly
saying you know
um he was making this Sunni share thing
as if like we are in each other's necks
like we are looking like when I see a
share on the road I do a drive-by like
I'm like I'm ready to kill people or
Muslims at large that's not the reality
genuinely that's not the reality that's
not what's happening you know and so
it's it's this you know um uh Colonius
Colonial mindset of like you know the
the I'm not talking about himself but
you know like the white man talking to
us as like you barbarians you know stop
killing each other and stop doing this
and stop hating everyone and focus on
that's how he came across I'm just being
honest once again I don't believe it was
malicious but it was disappointing
because and one thing that was
repeatedly been said in a condescending
condescending way was that you know
instead of hating you know the shias and
the Christians and the Jews Like There's
this kind of
um uh like the way he was saying it the
demeanor he was using who's emphasizing
on the Jews I mean if we look at History
Jordan Peterson Jews were being
persecuted by Christians a left right
center and why because of the killing of
the god of Christianity which is Jesus
yes that's why Christianity and the
Crusaders and in history you will know
that they were under persecution
severely and they would most times run
to Muslim lands for you know to not to
be killed you know so to use this over
and over again I find it very bizarre
you know it's it's like we need to know
our history and as a Christian man
yourself Jordan Peterson you know when
you spot the Mohammed his friend I was
right there in that room I could it was
a beautiful discussion we saw you you
know tearing up when he was listening to
him I genuinely believe you're sincere
but this really was not needed and I
understand your call to coming together
in United like Allah says in the Quran
in Surah
um
come together towards righteousness and
we are told to do that so much
say that in the Battle of bada the first
war that the the companions the prophet
Muhammad and the the companions were
fighting against the Pagan Arabs who
were persecuting them we know that in
history that when the Christians
Byzantine the Roman army defeated the
Persians the Muslims were also rejoicing
at the same time of that double Victory
because they won the war against the
pagans also at the same time they got
the news that the Christians the Romans
defeated the Persians so this was a
rejoicing moment why because the people
of the book like yourself are close to
us Allah says in the Quran
now the people of the book are not the
same there are some of those who worship
God Almighty and that follows obedience
the point is this that we are told that
the people of the book are not the same
be the Jews of the Christians so the
thing is to generalize and make us as if
we hate Jews I'm so sorry that's not
true with the prophet's wife was a Jew
yes there was many prophets that was
there were two right so the thing is we
do not hate them so this misconception
which has been finally spread uh you
know why they spent spread by the far
right so once again please draw the
pieces I urge I like watching the stuff
I watch just I binge watch your stuff
the Muslim Community love your stuff and
we are
shoulder to shoulder uncertain matters
when it comes to dealing with a big
Satan like we said for example but the
thing is it is not nice when you make it
out to be as these people who are just
too busy because once again in that
video unintentionally intentionally you
came across as if you're you're talking
to a group of Barbarians yeah you know
it's it's like the The White Man's
Burden you know you're there to help us
you know you're the intelligent or
something barbarians stop killing each
other you know it's not nice I'll be
honest with you as a Muslim myself when
I watched that I was very disappointed
and once again I know it's not malicious
but my point just to wrap it up is that
and I'll finish with this verse in the
Quran where God Almighty says that in
chapter 60 verse 8 Allah God Almighty
does not forbid you it does not um
forbid you to do just The Uncanny with
those who fought and not against you on
account of your religion no draw you out
of your homes verily Allah loves those
who deal with equity
it is only as regards it is only as
regards those who fought against you on
account of your religion and had driven
you out of your homes and helped to
drive you out that Allah forbid you to
befriend them and whoever will befriend
them they are the wrongdoers so God
Almighty is very and this is not
abrogated by the way some people come
say oh this person this was a peaceful
verse no this person abrogated which
clearly tells us that we are to deal
just the unkindly with the clues and the
Christians and the people that did not
attack US based on our faith okay as
kicks out of our houses it's as simple
as that so please we just urge you as a
Muslim Community I mean we're not
writing you off but we're just saying
please be very careful because it just
seems you're saying things that you do
not you are not aware of you know we do
not hate the Jews any Jews rabbis in
history have claimed have have admitted
that the Muslims took them in when they
were under severe persecution by the
Christians and even one Rabbi I asked
you forgot his name I can't recall it he
said if the Muslims were ruling in the
World War II or you know in in Nazi
Germany there'll be six million extra
Jews today so please let's get rid of
this notion that we Muslims have this
hatred towards Christians and Jews and
you know shias and everyone else this is
really really not the case and I urge
you please Dr Peterson please if you can
read the Quran and I'm sure you are but
please if you can you know if you have
questions on this matter to get in
contact with Muhammad hijab or anyone
else of the likes that can maybe give
you some more information because once
again it was disappointing but um we
will assume the best as Muslims you know
that you didn't mean it in that way but
it's just a video that I had to get out
of my uh chess